CARLEY:  BACK WITH A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP AVERTING A
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN, SIGNING THE
MASSIVE $2.3 TRILLION SPENDING
BILL WHICH INCLUDES $900 BILLION
IN CORONAVIRUS RELIEF.
TODD:  THE EMERGENCY FUNDS IN
THE RELIEF DEAL INCLUDE $600
PAYMENTS FOR EVERY ADULT AND
CHILD, EXTRA $300 A WEEK IN
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS FOR 11
WEEKS, $284 BILLION IN FUNDING
FOR PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM
AND EXTENDING THE EVICTION
MORATORIUM.
CARLEY:  ON CAPITOL HILL,
CONGRESS WILL VOTE ON THE
PRESIDENT’S DEMAND FOR $2,000
CHECKS TO EVERY AMERICAN.
TODD:  THOSE CHECKS A MAJOR
STICKING POINT BETWEEN
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS.
>> IT’S TERRIBLY UNTARGETTED,
RIGHT.
WHY WOULD WE BE SENDING $2,000
TO PEOPLE WITH A SIX FIGURE
INCOME WHO HAVE HAD NO
SUSPENSION, NO REDUCTION OF
THEIR INCOME AT ALL.
>> GIVEN THE TERRIBLE ECONOMIC
CRISIS FACING THIS COUNTRY, YES,
WE DO NEED TO GET $2,000 OUT TO
EVERY WORKING CLASS INDIVIDUAL
IN THIS COUNTRY.
TODD:  SO DID PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
STRATEGY HELP OR HURT DEMOCRATIC
STRATEGIST ROBERT PATILLO AND
ANALYST RON MEYER JOIN US NOW.
DID THE PRESIDENT HELP THE
SITUATION OR HURT IT.
>> HE HURT THE SITUATION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD THE ABILITY
TO COME OUT OVER THE SUMMER OR
IN THE SPRING AND SAY HE WAS
GOING TO DEMAND $2,000 DIRECT
PAYMENTS TO INDIVIDUALS.
WHY WOULD YOU WAIT UNTIL THE
ENTIRE BILL HAS ALREADY BEEN
NEGLIGENCE OTHER OF YATESED AND
-- NEGOTIATED AND PASSED IN
ORDER TO THROW A MONKEY WRENCH
IN THE MIDDLE OF IT.
THE CHECKS COULD HAVE BEEN GOING
ON THIS WEEK ACCORDING TO
TREASURY SECRETARY MNUCHIN BUT
IT WAS HALTED.
OF COURSE HE HURT THE PROCESS.
TODD:  IS ROBERT RIGHT OR IS
THIS NANCY PELOSI’S FAULT FOR
BACK IN THE SUMMER DEMANDING A
GAZILLION DOLLARS, NOT THE
OFFICIAL NUMBER BUT IT FELT LIKE
IT, IN HER RELIEF DEAL.
>> WE CAN PLAY THE BLAME GAME
ALL DAY.
TRUMP SUPPORTED $2,000 PLUS
PAYMENTS FOR AS LONG AS I CAN
REMEMBER, GOING BACK TO JUNE.
THE DEMOCRATS DID PASS
SOMETHING, WITH EVERY RIDER AND
SPENDING PACKAGE THAT WAS THEIR
DREAM INCLUDING BAILING OUT
STATES THAT HAVEN’T BEEN SMART
WITH THEIR MONEY OF.
I THINK WE CAN GO BACK AND FORTH
AND BLAME, SAY IT COULD HAVE
BEEN EARLIER.
THE DEMOCRATS WERE NEVER GOING
TO PASS A BILL BEFORE THE
ELECTION THAT THE PRESIDENT
WOULD ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO SIGN
SO THEY FILLED IT WITH STUFF
THAT WOULD MAKE IT TOTALLY
UNSIGNABLE BECAUSE THEY WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT NOTHING PASSED
BEFORE JOE BIDEN WAS ABLE TO
SECURE VICTORY.
AND SO THAT’S BEEN THEIR
STRATEGY FROM DAY ONE AND SO I
THINK THE PRESIDENT -- I THINK
THE PRESIDENT SUPPORTED BIG
CHECKS FOR A LONG TIME HE STILL
SUPPORTS THEM.
HE WOULD SUPPORT A STAND-ALONE
RIDER THAT INCREASES IT TO TWO
GRAND.
AT THIS POINT NO ONE IS CARING
ABOUT FEDERAL SPENDING AND THE
PRESIDENT UNDERSTANDS THAT.
I THINK HE FEELS THAT DIRECT
PAYMENTS ARE GIVING PEOPLE THEIR
MONEY BACK.
WE’RE SENDING MONEY ACROSS THE
WORLD TO VARIOUS FOREIGN
COUNTRIES.
TODD:  THE PRESIDENT FIRMING UP
HIS GEORGIA RALLY PLANNED FOR
THE DAY BEFORE THE CRITICAL
RUNOFFS IN THE PEACH STATE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, ROBERT?
DO YOU THINK THE STIMULUS
SIGNING IS GOING TO SWAY VOTERS
IN ANY WAY, SHAPE OR FORM OR OF
ARE THE RESULTS IN THIS ONE
ALREADY BAKED IN.
>> YOU HAD KELLY LOEFFLER
SPENDING A HALF BILLION DOLLARS
ON COMMERCIALS, CRITICIZING
RAPHAEL WARNOCK FOR WANTING TO
MAKE CORRECT PAYMENTS TO
INDIVIDUALS AND A WEEK BEFORE
THE ELECTION PRESIDENT TRUMP
COMING OUT TALKING ABOUT THE THI
THESE PEOPLE HAVE CONSISTENTLY
DEMONSTRATED THEY FEEL THAT
DIRECT PAYMENTS TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE UNNECESSARY BUT TO
HELP BILLIONAIRES AND
MILLIONAIRES IS WHAT THEY CARE
OUT OF.
I DON’T THINK DONALD TRUMP IS
GOING TO CHANGE THAT WITH A TRIP
GEORGIA NEXT WEEK.
TODD:  RON, YOUR RESPONSE.
>> I THINK THE CURRENT
INCUMBENT SENATORS VOTED FOR THE
RELIEF.
THEY SUPPORTED ADDITIONAL RELIEF
FROM TIME TO TIME.
WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO REALLY IS
MOMENTUM AND PEOPLE WANTING A
TRUE CHECK ON GOVERNMENT.
YOU KNOW, WHEN THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT GETS SWORN IN
JANUARY 20th, PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO WANT TO KNOW THERE’S A CHECK
AND BALANCE.
IF THE DEMOCRATS HOLD THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE AND THE
PRESIDENCY, I DON’T THINK THAT’S
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT.
I THINK THEY WANT DIVIDED
GOVERNMENT, THEY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT D.C. IS FORCED TO
COMPROMISE AND THAT ONE PARTY
DOESN’T RUN OVER ANOTHER.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE GEORGIA
SENATE RACES, I THINK THAT’S
WHAT IT COMES DOWN TO.
ESPECIALLY WITH CANDIDATES ON
THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE THAT AREN’T
IN LINE WITH MODERATE,
COMPROMISING VALUES, THEY’RE
HARD CORE, PROGRESSIVE
DEMOCRATS.
DO WE WANT THE SENATE TO BE
TAKEN OVER IN THAT WAY WHEN WE
COULD HAVE ONE PARTY CONTROL, I
DON’T THINK SO.
I THINK THAT’S WHY YOU’RE GOING
TO SEE PRESIDENT TRUMP GO DOWN
THERE TO TRY TO GET THE MOMENTUM
FOR THE REPUBLICANS TO CLOSE
THIS THING OFF AND I THINK THAT
REPUBLICANS DO HAVE THE SLIGHT
MOMENTUM HERE.
IT’S GOING TO BE CLOSE.
TODD:  YOU HAVE TO WON OF DEER
IF THE PRESIDENT REALLY --
WONDER IF THE PRESIDENT REALLY
HELD HIS NOSE AND SWALLOWED HIS
MEDICINE, EVEN THOUGH HE HATES
THE PORK IN THE BILL, HE DOESN’T
WANT TO DO ANYTHING ABOUT